efe es una función lineal que toma
valores conforme a la siguiente tabla
aquí nos dan algunos valores de x y los
valores que toman f en esos puntos
cuáles gráficas corresponden a funciones
que crecen más rápido que s y aquí nos
dan estas cuatro gráficas ahora bien que
algo crezca que una función crezca más
rápido que ese lo que quiere decir es
que su tasa de cambio promedio es más
grande en el caso de funciones lineales
como estas líneas rectas o es efe que
nos dicen que es función lineal lo que
significa es que la tasa de cambio entre
el eje vertical y el eje horizontal
tiene que ser más grande que la de f así
que vamos a encontrar cuál es la tasa de
cambio la tasa de cambio se define por
cuánto cambias cuánto cambia tu función
dividido entre cuánto cambia tu variable
ok para algún cambio de la variable
cuánto cambia la función recuerden este
triangulito es la letra griega habla así
que bien analicemos aquí si mi función
de gemelos no toca abajo delta
entre delta x esto es igual a cuanto si
aquí cambio x por 1 que incremente a x
en 1 entonces ese aumento en 5
por lo tanto tengo mi cambio en x fue 1
y mi cambio en f fue de 5 podría ser lo
mismo acá que aumente x en uno y aquí
aumente x perdón
efe en 5 y como es lineal de hecho
siempre va a ser la misma tasa de cambio
incluso si fuera digamos desde el 1
hasta el 3 en donde aumente x por dos
unidades delta x es 2 y delta efe sería
10 porque estoy pasando en menos 9 a 1
positivo
10 entre 2 de nuevo es 5 así que mi
pendiente o mi tasa de cambio es 5 ahora
quiero encontrar que gráficas
corresponden a funciones que cambian más
rápido que f es decir que tienen una
tasa de cambio promedio mayor a 5 ahora
bien a podemos notar que está
decreciendo a no está creciendo está
disminuyendo por lo tanto a ni siquiera
la voy a achicar a no puede ser ahora ve
si yo me paro aquí en b me paro en este
punto que está sobre la gráfica y no me
muevo una unidad sobre el eje x entonces
tendría que alzar me cinco unidades para
tener una tasa de cambio igual a efe así
que veamos cuánto me alzó en este punto
ahora me alzó 1 2 3 4 5 unidades también
por lo tanto la tasa de cambio debe es
igual a la tasa de cambio de f no es que
esté creciendo más rápido simplemente
que tiene la misma tasa de cambio así
que ve tampoco funciona que hay dc100 si
yo me paro digamos aquí que es un punto
que tiene coordenadas enteras menos tres
como menos 2 y avanzó una unidad
una unidad en el eje x cuántas unidades
tengo que subir en el eje y pues tengo
que subir 1 2 3 4 5 6 6 y un poquito más
y entonces la tasa de cambio de esta
función es 6 más un cachito entre 1 que
es mayor a 5 por lo tanto se si funciona
y que hay de de nuevo me paro en un
punto con coordenadas enteras por
ejemplo este me muevo una unidad a la
derecha y me fijo en cuanto me alzó 1 2
3 3 y un poquito entonces 3 y un poquito
entre 1 sigue siendo menor a 5 por lo
tanto de crece más lentamente que efe la
tasa de cambio de d es menor a la de f y
por lo tanto la única función que crece
más rápido que f es la función que está
representada por la gráfica c